hi everyone its Johanna here I thought I
would take the time and share something
quite personal which I had struggled
with for over 2 to 3 years and that was
acne most of you might not know this but
I had pretty bad
acne from the end of 2009 till about
2012 so I wasn't blessed with natural
glowy skin or clear skin before I start
I just want to be clear that I am NOT a
skin expert in fact I have a very
limited knowledge in skincare and makeup
so what I'm sharing with you today is
based on my own personal experience and
what has worked for me what you're
looking at right now it's me without any
cream or foundation on just a little bit
of eye makeup because if I don't put any
eye makeup you will not be able to see
my eyes they're so small so as you can
see there's still a little bit of scar
and redness from my acne growing up as a
teenager I never had acne it first
started during my final year of college
and we came back right now it was really
done to poor nutrition lack of exercise
lack of sleep and high amount of stress
which messed up my hormones back in 2009
I was juggling b2 my college work
full-time internship and I also started
my part-time personal training course
over the weekends and what many was was
when I left home for college I did not
enjoy any more home-cooked meals and I
did not have a clue on how to make my
own meals so I was constantly eating out
every day on every single meals I did
not care what goes into my mouth how big
the portion was at what time of the day
so I was staying up really late at night
and I was eating a big greasy meal at 3
or 4 a.m. in the morning and I only had
about 3 or 4 hours of sleep a day so
this picture you're looking at right now
was taken towards the end of 2
that night when I first started
developing acne after a year of really
poor life style when I started
developing acne the first reaction was
to get stress and to get panic so I
decided to take things into my own hands
bearing in mind that I had very little
knowledge on skincare and nutrition at
that time every time I stand to the
mirror I would be really upset and my
hands would be touching my face trying
to pop and acne out instead of doing my
usual cleansing or to have a better diet
and lifestyle I ended up scrubbing my
face every day my thought was that the
more I scrub eventually all the acne
will pop out and disappear and of course
that did not happen and as you know it
only made my skin worse so I decided to
go to the pharmacies and get some
medications I start to apply the
medication and I guess what I was
looking for was a miracle cream I was
hoping that by applying the medication
for a week and it would just go off I
even did my own online research trying
to look for a miracle cream just like
some of you who might be looking for a
quick fix on weight loss
I bought the cream and of course nothing
worked eventually I ended up going to a
dermatologist and to be honest it wasn't
a really positive experience for me in
his opinion my skin condition was
nothing in comparison to his other
patients so all he did was to stare at
my face for about 30 seconds and I'm not
even kidding
give me some medications and cream to
apply and off I go so I did apply the
cream and took the medications for the
next six months and it did help to
improve my acne but once I stopped it
came back again and it's because I did
not get down to the core of the problem
which was my really poor lifestyle bad
nutrition lack of exercise and just
constant stress and lack of sleep all
these events happen in a cost of just
over a year and at a time I really
really hate to looking at myself in the
mirror it's because before my acne I
used to do
part-time modeling and acting and once I
had my acne I wasn't able to do any of
that anymore and so looking at myself
every day in the mirror just made myself
hated the way I look
eventually I got fed up and just give up
on treatments and really not caring
about myself anymore
and unknowingly at that time I started
looking more into my own nutrition
exercise and sleeping habits as I
started working as a personal trainer so
I started exercising on a regular basis
care more about my food slap at least
eight hours per night and this helped to
reduce my stress level all of this did
not happen overnight
in fact it happened over two years of
ups and downs and eventually when I came
to the UK towards in the end of 2010 my
skin started to break out again because
I wasn't used to the weather here it was
too dry for me adjusting to the food
here was another challenge for me so
being so far away from home and not
having much I had to start prepping my
own meals with very limited knowledge I
prep really basic meals which I believe
actually helped me towards curing my
acne and what was really important for
me was when I learned to put my physical
appearance aside to be able to look into
the mirror and to be truly happy with
who I am despite having a lot of acne
slowly as my frustration and stress went
away day by day I had clearer and
clearer skin so let me share with you 10
tips that has worked for me let me start
with nutrition the first tip is to eat
basic real food as much as you can try
to prep your own meals eating out too
often and not knowing what goes into my
food was one of the causes to my acne
what I mean by basic real food is to
choose whole food minimal ingredients
which doesn't require much time to prep
at all so my food recipes videos are
basically the type of food I have been
consuming for the past two years which
has helped towards my acne
it has helped towards my weight
maintenance as well the second tip is to
cut down on greasy food consuming greasy
food really messes with my digestion and
it makes me feel as though my pores are
opening up and it gives me early skin I
know there are no proven science behind
this but this is based on my own
personal experience and cutting down on
greasy food has helped me to gain
clearer skin this then leads on to my
next point which is to consume more food
that helps with better digestion when I
had my acne I had a really poor
digestion not only did I feel bloated
almost every day poor digestion has
caused my skin pores to clock so foods
that help with digestion are basically
foods which are high in fiber and water
content such as vegetables and fruits my
all-time favorite is banana food that
you should avoid are greasy fried oily
food and dairy products if you are
lactose intolerance the fourth tip is to
be aware of your sodium intake this is
true in my case when I used to eat out
every single day the meals I used to
consume were either processed food fast
food or meals which are high in sodium
not only if these meals made me feel so
bloated but they also managed to ruin my
skin so again it comes down to the
principle of preparing your own meals
it's in clean unprocessed food which are
low in sodium this has made me feel
better
and to give me clearer skin as well tip
number 5 is to drink more water as
obvious as this might sound sometimes
with our busy schedule especially during
my stressful period we tend to forget to
keep ourselves hydrated at all time
drinking more water helps to flush our
internal toxins which has helped to
reduce my break out tremendously and
drinking more water has also kept my
skin hydrated inside out and this was
needed when I first came to the UK and
when I was still adjusting to the dry
weather here
Plus drinking water helps to keep you
young helps to keep the weight off and
to stay fit
so keep drinking and drinking another
method I use to get more fluid into my
body is to consume food with high water
content when I was in Malaysia I used to
drink a lot of coconut water and
watermelon juice are the foods with high
water content include strawberries
zucchinis cucumbers spinach tomatoes
broccolis and more what you can do is to
boil and blend your favorite vegetables
to make a thick and creamy vegetable
soup which is currently my favorite dish
the next tip is to cleanse twice a day
again this is my son really obvious but
when I was awake at 3 or 4 a.m. in the
morning I wasn't thinking about
cleansing my face so just like getting
into a fitness routine I had to get
myself into a cleansing routine to
cleanse in the morning and at night and
to trust that all these changes I'm
making every day will help towards my
skin remember my acne did not go away
overnight it was 2 to 3 years of ups and
downs for me so just like losing weight
you have to start making the changes and
to trust that all these positive changes
you're making will help towards your
results for those of you who do your
regular exercises threat from exercising
can also lead to breakouts by your skin
irritation especially around your
forehead so it is very important for you
to cleanse and shower right after your
workouts and to wear fresh clothes do
not wait for hours to shower shower once
you have cooled down tip number 8 is do
not skip on your beauty sleep lack of
sleep increases stress and stress leads
to breakup and weight gain I personally
experienced both of this in my final
year of college when I finally get my
life back into more of an order
naturally my skin starts to appear
as well so even up to today if I like my
beauty sleep I can see and feel the
difference on my skin sleep for at least
seven to eight hours every day the next
tip is to exercise regularly exercising
has so many more health benefits
including clear skin exercising on a
regular basis has helped me to reduce my
stress level and to regulate my hormone
levels which is one of the main causes
of acne so if you want clearer skin
filter body better health and to look
good and feel good inside out do your
regular exercises my final and most
important tip is focus on the change and
not the problem this is true whether
you're struggling with acne or to lose
weight or any other life circumstances
focusing on the problem will not make
the problem go away instead focus your
energy into making the changes which
will eventually solve the problem I had
to learn this the hard way my acne will
not go away in fact it only was done
with the stress and self-hatred my skin
only became clearer when I started to
love myself again to focus on the
positive changes I made daily and to
slowly reboot my confidence by putting
my physical appearance aside hence I
always believe that we have to learn to
love ourselves as who we are right now
before any changes can happen just like
being consistent with your workout and
meal plan to lose weight I had to be
consistent with my skincare routine in
order for my acne to heal once you have
set your mind to a goal my being to cure
my acne you have to stop having doubts
and start having faith that every
positive changes you make will only lead
you towards your goal no matter how long
it will take you stick by it
it took me two years to have clear skin
but this has helped me to regain my
confidence and for me to love myself
even more so start having faith for new
fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do follow me
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter to
stay connected with me thanks guys